I'm having more discomfort pain from the tumors.
Can you recommend something to help naturally?
Any of the anti-inflammatory things,
so the anti-inflammatory things are the flavonoids,
the curcumin, the Boswellia, the betelene from
beats, which the only product that has
pure betelene for the beats is the aloevia product.
And then the white willow bark, the,
so things that are in our clear inflamed product,
so the anti-inflammatory things are what you want to do.
Those are the things that will naturally decrease the pain.
You can also think of artica.
You can get artica as an herb,
or you can get artica as a homeopath.
Those are the things that some people really respond
really well to artica.
Also, think of CBD.
CBD can be helpful.
And if it's legal in your state, THC, THC gummies
can be super helpful.
It can really help you sleep.
The only negative of that, it can make you a little bit loopy
and some people don't like that,
but take it before bed, it can give you a good night's sleep.
That could be one of your best bets.